today I'm putting together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner with an
American flavor I've traveled throughout
the United States for my work and as
well as having some shockingly bad meals
over there I've also had some brilliant
ones and right now the U.S food scene is
really vibrant lots of new talented
young chefs incorporating new flavors
into the dishes and Reinventing American
Classics taking my cue from some of the
best this is my ultimate American Home
Cooking first up for breakfast my take
on a U.S Diner classic eggs baked with
crispy hash browns and Smoky sweet bacon
for lunch the mighty American Caesar
salad with brittle chicken breast and a
big bold dressing followed by peanut
butter and jam cookies to die for
time for a little drink and middle
daughter Holly joins me in the kitchen
you put yours in there I'll put mine
here sad we're creating an American
Feast with barbecue style beef brisket
crunching like coleslaw and spicy sweet
potato wedges this is my ultimate
American food breakfast lunch and dinner
first up eggs baked in hash browns
The Secret of a great hash brown
other potatoes I prefer using really
nice waxy potatoes they cook better but
more importantly
pull themselves together
we're not going to slice the onion all
the potatoes but we're actually going to
grate them the potatoes get really nice
and crispy I mean seriously crispy now
the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
that onion flavor running through every
little Shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
squeeze
pull that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important the more
liquid you remove the crispier your hash
browns will be
nice large pan put that on
once the Pan's hot pour in a good glug
of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms
how important it is to have your pan
nice and hot
so it seals
the grated potato onion together
to take the spoon
and just
Pat it down what we're trying to do now
is get it really nice and compact
going around the outside of the pan with
a little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelized
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over
and then slide it back in very quickly
you see the color
we've got on there now
got that nice crispy texture
of the potato I'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
packing your eggs nice and gently just a
little sprinkling of the can
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven for six to eight
minutes meanwhile onto my bacon and I'm
giving it a classic American twist now
one thing I could never get my head
around when I first started eating lots
of American breakfast was the sweetness
from the bacon I've grown up to love
that combination of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil brown sugar salt and pepper
and butter bacon in and as it Cooks it
becomes irresistibly caramelized and
golden brown Turf of gas
and my glazed bacon
it's absolutely ready beautiful
now my hash browns and baked eggs are
ready
beautiful just
get your spatula underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon
sets beautifully on top of the baked
eggs and that hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfast in
the world are always in America
this is an All-American superhero offer
breakfast eggs bacon hash browns with
glazed bacon
[Music]
next I'm showing you a fantastic
American inspired lunch and dinner
[Music]
to go to the US to buy the ingredients
here's a closer look at the key ones
first up it's beef brisket a cheap cut
from the breast of the cow
it's underused in the UK but loved by
American cousins and used for incredible
delicates like Pastrami and succulent
salt beef
the key to beef brisket is to cook it
low and slow to make it tender and I've
got a delicious barbecue style recipe
for dinner
[Music]
next sweet potatoes as American as apple
pie
sometimes called yams in the USA they're
native to the tropical Americans they
cook quicker than standard potatoes
they're packed with nutrients and have a
fantastic sweet flavor whether you mash
them bake them or roast them but I
really love the simple sweet potato
wedges I'm making for dinner
[Music]
the ultimate American staple has to be
peanut butter and more than half the
peanuts grown in the U.S are used to
make it
I love it both crunchy or smooth and not
just spread on bread it's fantastic and
savory sauces like Satay or even in
desserts like the peanut butter and jam
cookies I'm making for lunch
the main course will be a crispy Big
Caesar salad but the first job are my
peanut butter and jam cookies
[Music]
start with the cookie dough simply
combine muscovado sugar peanut butter
and butter until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
sift together salt baking powder and
flour
[Music]
and mix until thoroughly combined
[Music]
in floured hands roll the cookie dough
into golf ball sizes flatten and create
an indent with your finger fill with
half jam and half peanut butter
place the cookies on a tray lined with
baking paper and bake in a preheated
oven for 10 to 12 minutes
before serving
[Music]
next job main course and my take on an
iconic American salad first made almost
a century ago Caesar salad is definitely
a classic but the trick to keeping
dishes like this modern and relevant is
to tweak them but not lose what made
them brilliant in the first place here's
my version for the ultimate American
lunch my first twist is in the dressing
for me the most important part of the
Caesar salad is that dressing
Rich creamy slightly spicy
Begin by making a basic mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks then just
a little spoon Dijon and then a little
splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzle in your olive oil
should fall through
your whisk it's like a nice thick
double cream texture
beautiful
now take the Mayo to another level with
Anchovies and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together
so we almost want that to be like a
really nice
puree then grated Parmesan lemon juice
that will make the dressing
citrusy
lighter in color and then a little
splash of water
and
now
all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing
delicious
light dressing
nice
job the croutons and I like using crusty
bread for extra Crunch and just dice up
your bread season with salt and pepper
then add to a hot pan with olive oil and
Fry give that a really nice toss as the
croutons start to turn golden simply
great on a generous amount of Parmesan
cheese keep them rolling around stop
them from sticking together look at that
really nice cheesy delicious
Crouton and now they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
Caesar salad starting with Romaine
lettuce and don't slice the lettuce too
thinly
a squeeze of lemon on with half of that
gutsy anchovy Mayo dressing
saving some to coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons
look at that a really nice mix
salad in it's all beautifully dressed
add the remaining croutons and finish
with a good grating of Parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect season salad
however I'm going to take it to another
level and grill a stunning
to breast start by preheating your
griddle pan then butterfly your chicken
breast simply slice from the thin end
towards the thick bit of the breast Put
The Knife do the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and just nice and moist in the
center
season the chicken on both sides with
salt and ground pepper lay your chicken
breast onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill until you're
absolutely ready to cook the chicken now
turn them over
beautiful
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chicken's got those
lovely Stripes from The Griddle which
adds a gorgeous Smoky flavor whilst they
rest spoon over some of the remaining
anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down the flavor the
seasoning of the anchovy the garlic and
the parmesan seeps into that chicken
slice the chicken into strips
wow
I serve the chicken warm in a separate
Bowl so it doesn't Wilt the salad spoon
the dressing
finish that with a little touch of
dressing
an American classic
I think one of the most popular sellers
anywhere in the world but it's still the
most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch this really is an
American Dream a delicious Caesar salad
and succulent Golden Griddle chicken
with peanut butter and jam cookies for
dessert
there comes the cooking techniques
barbecue is virtually a religion in
America especially in the southern
states down there the real barbecue Pros
use big open fire pits to get huge
joints of meat super succulent and
fantastically perfume with smoke and
spice so mild to my American dinner has
to include an amazing melt-in-the-mouth
barbecue beef but I'm doing it the easy
way cooked in the oven low and slow
my family I spent a lot of time in the
US and they love American food
joining me in the kitchen today is
Jack's twin sister Holly we're creating
barbecue style beef brisket with crunchy
coleslaw and sweet potato wedges which
will be right up her Street
Holly
now
you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket
look at that beautiful it was a very
tough cut of meat so it needs to be
cooked slowly so it gets really nice and
tender barbecuing it outside we're going
to actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're going to cook it in the
oven okay so mustard powder okay here we
have some celery seed next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
because now what I want you to do
fresh pepper on there
I'll give that a little mix roll up your
little sleeves and then
I want you
to rub
all that spice into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice SO gas on roasting tray on
what we've got to do now with all those
spices is sear them in a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil into the tray
all done okay that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket and all
that spice
throw that in there nicely okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices yep all that spice left on the
plate
we're gonna use yeah
I want you to get the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
foreign
spices now
good girl thank you
damn Holly
was homework that bad no the onions oh
no don't rub your eyes don't rub your
eyes
[Music]
we've got the color
look on the brisket okay yeah
yeah take that out literally for 30
seconds okay onions into the tray please
nice
you see it started to smell slightly
barbecuing already give that a little
stir
nice now one nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
what does the brown sugar do that so the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my Bailey's in please
good girl yes please right we'll take
over
that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon of tomato puree roast that
off at the bottom of the tray you really
rub it in amongst the onions good girl
now look at the color of those onions
right now time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there I'll put
mine here good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball okay now this is
where it gets really exciting I want you
to lift the brisket up and put it on top
of the onions and she goes
good girl
and then I want you to pour the stock
all the way around please
I'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil and just pinch
in the ends
turn that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it Cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoke paprika dried oregano cayenne
pepper and mix spice mix done now simply
cut your sweet potatoes into wedges toss
in olive oil and thoroughly cover with
the spice mix
onto a bacon tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh now look at that so we can leave that
to rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
mayonnaise this time we're gonna do it a
little different so I'd like to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
place all of it I'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar in there okay as
I shred this okay I'd like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix in at the same time and then you
fold that in there as I start shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now for
the white
so got that nice vinegary tartness for
the slaw and the yogurt keeps it nice
and fresh
little bit in
one more little thing
so
it was a nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give you this nice light
onion flavor
so chives in
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
like you
to fill up the bowl I'm going to very
carefully lift out my brisket how come
chunk it's been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
and start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first before anybody
that is so good that
taste
delicious see all that wonderful flavor
in there last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
and reduce the spicy juices and onions
the beef cooked in then add inside of
vinegar and you add a brilliant Tangy
barbecue sauce
smells nice
brisket
now the rest of it
should go in the gravy pot
that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my darling is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me I've got the
brisket wow
let's go Donnie well done by the way
thank you this is a real American Beauty
gorgeous low and slow cooked barbecue
beef brisket with three potato wedges
and yogurt coleslaw
Megan Jack hi Tilly big deep Smoky
flavors that bring the taste of the
American South to your kitchen
who'd like some coleslaw
s and who'd like some gravy thank you
but it's spicy and slightly barbecue
how's the brisket really good
amazing with the gravy
and what do you think
is that
I'm pretty good you think so yeah if
you're not as good as mine but I can
feel
a lot of competition
in amongst the Ramsey girls good job
thank you there are loads more great
home cooking recipes on my app cook with
me you can find it in the App Store good
luck
I love a great party but I hate bad food
and often the two things go together I
think one of the reasons is that home
Cooks get intimidated by the thought of
cooking for large crowds so they give up
and serve shop walk food instead but
trust me with a bit of planning and
great recipes it's easy this is my
Ultimate Party food first up a great
brunch for a crowd spicy Mexican eggs
for a sophisticated party lunch you can
pre-prepare beetroot cured salmon and a
chocolate mint cake little sheets of
glass beautiful my eldest daughter Megan
will be helping me rustle up some
amazing dishes for a relaxed Ramsay
get-together that's all right with
irresistible Smoky pulled pork just
don't tell mum thank you
simple but delicious sides of broccoli
slaw and crushed potatoes with spring
onions and gruya cheese
I've never had this before so good these
are my ultimate party recipes that will
entertain and sustain a house full of
guests for breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with the breakfast that can't
fail to get your guests fired up and
ready to party
spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see
you're right through to dinner now to
start the sort of spicy fragrant tomato
sauce get your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
that are embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven proof dish
for my spicy egg brunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in Mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
got a really nice rich delicious strong
Montgomery cheddar I want a grape the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top and we'll season that
with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg just salt
a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
it's a little bit of coriander to finish
it off and that for me is what brunch is
all about let's go
thank you
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs and a
crispy tortilla shell
[Music]
coming up my ultimate food for lunch or
evening party
but first here's a closer look at the
key ingredients you'll need and a few
pointers on what to look for when you're
buying them
[Music]
chocolate the ultimate comfort food
addictive and indulgent the chocolate
making process begins by grinding
roasted cocoa beans
quality chocolate should contain at
least 70 cocoa solids it should give a
distinctive crisp snap when broken and
start melting in your hand after just a
few seconds and there'll be no skimping
on the quality for my party lunch
chocolate mint cake
pork shoulder is an easy to cook flavor
some joint and can be brought on the
bone or rolled It's relatively cheap
price makes it a great choice when
you're feeding a crowd marbled with fat
to keep it moisture and cooking it's
also the cut of choice for barbecue
pulled pork known affectionately in the
U.S as Boston butts I'll be cooking my
delicious version of this meltingly good
export as the star guest on my dinner
party
[Applause]
sodium chloride or salt is a mineral
essential to human life it's also one of
the most widely used seasonings in the
world it's lack of Aroma belies its
strong taste which both enhances the
natural flavor of food and stimulates
our taste buds this seasoning of all
seasonings is processed in various ways
and comes in all different colors and
forms but for me the finest in flavor is
crystallized sea salt the product of
evaporated seawater and is what I'll be
using to cure my salmon the main course
for my super simple but spectacular
party lunch
I think the best dishes for lunch
parties are the things that everyone can
help themselves too I also prefer dishes
that pack a really big flavor punch and
look impressive party food shouldn't be
subtle here are a couple of dishes for
my ultimate lunch party
the secret behind during salmon is in
the flavoring you're curing it with for
a hint of the Exotic and aromatic my
favorite starting point is to grind
coriander seeds
coriander seeds are citrusy it's got
that nice orangey flavor and it goes
brilliantly well with salmon
mix that with your salt and your sugar
it may look like a lot of salt and sugar
but once they've done their job of cold
cooking or curing the salmon most of it
will be washed away
next the greatest zest of two oranges
fresh pepper
and then mix in one of my favorite
ingredients grated beetroot
beetroot gives a really nice sort of
Rooty earthy flavor great for curing it
stains the salmon as well and it just
elevates it
now
you'll see what's happening now with a
beetroot the salt and sugar breaking it
down see how wet it's becoming now that
beetroot is ready for the salmon
if you've got a big party 10 or 20. you
get a whole side of salmon fill it and
get it pin boned by a fishmonger if it's
six or ten guests then this Chunk in the
middle is like the sort of middle part
of a fillet steak The Best of the Best
pour on your beetroot and basically what
we're going to do now is sort of pack it
with all the beetroot and look at that I
mean it looks fantastic
next cover your beet Rooty salmon with
climb film take your tray
lightly press and they get something
substantial something heavy a pot
a pan or some tins the weight on top
just speeds up the process
[Music]
in the fridge to cure for at least eight
hours or even better overnight
[Music]
we follow my deliciously light and
simple salmon a devilishly indulgent
dessert nothing beats a great cake a
sort of a show-off trophy for party
foods I'm going to make the most amazing
flourless chocolate cake but with a
Twist first thing first make the caramel
flatten the sugar never stir a caramel
rule number one now keep the pan nice
and flat
I'm going to flavor this caramel with a
little bit of mint give it a little chop
sprinkle that into the caramel
don't get the caramel too dark just nice
and light a little teaspoon of oil onto
the tray and rub that in
and then pour out
your camera if I was making a caramel
sauce then I'd put butter and cream into
the caramel but I want this nice minted
brittle running through my cake whilst
the candle cools down on a tray I'm
going to make my cake
first melt good quality dark chocolate
in a bammary
eating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats always in a bowl
over boiling water in a mixing bowl
sugar two whole eggs and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs and the sugar
a lighter that texture in the center of
the chocolate cake next melt some butter
into your warm dark chocolate and stir
puts that really nice Sheen velvety rich
and tasting amazing add that to your
sugar and your eggs
hmm
I give that a really good mix
and when you're making flourless
desserts it really is important to work
harder incorporating air especially with
the yolks and the sugar that natural
height needs to take place at the
beginning look at that it's like the
perfect chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two thirds of
the way there with your whites and then
just sprinkle in your sugar it's almost
like a meringue and the firmer you make
these now the more it will elevate your
cake in the oven
foreign
[Music]
that's what you call a stiff peak
in with the whites before I start mixing
that I'll get my camera
just start breaking that up it's a
little glass sheets of glass beautiful
and save some of your minty caramel
shards for decoration and use a rolling
pin to break up the rest into small
pieces sprinkle that in
so as we start to slice that chocolate
cake you'll come across that nice crunch
take your cake tin
make sure it's lined with the grease
with paper
on the bottom nicely greased
pour this in
sharp Taps on a hard surface or rid your
cake mixture of any air pockets that
could create holes in your cake
sit that in the oven
180.
after 35 minutes my chocolate mint cake
is cooked and whilst it cools down I can
whip up a peppermint cream topping
[Music]
add sifted icing sugar and a few drops
of peppermint extract to double cream
and whisk until it's just holding its
shape
[Music]
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small border free to make
it easier to cut for a cake that can't
fail to attract attention at your party
scatter over the remaining caramel mint
shards
[Music]
now to unveil my incredible beetroot
cured salmon
offer the weight
that's right
and look what's happened to the salmon
absolutely beautiful
you can just tell how delicious that's
going to be with this sort of Sheen give
that a little rinse in cold water
with your kitchen roll Pat it nice and
dry
beautiful
traditionally cured salmon would be
sliced into large thin pieces like
smoked salmon but I like to cut mine
Into Thin strips it's easier and it will
show off its beauty
slice down get to the skin and then
flick your knife out
that for me is a much better way of
eating cured salmon
look at the difference the colors that
nice dark Rich ruby red
now when you've got cured salmon this
good trust me you just need a salad
melbour toast or some stunning bread
look how many slices of salmon we've got
Master secret for me to any good party a
couple masterpieces simple
straightforward ingredients but done
properly
foreign
[Music]
cured salmon and for dessert a Divine
chocolate mint cake party food with the
wow factor
[Music]
when you work in a restaurant your job
is to make sure people have a great time
you're there to make sure they're
enjoying themselves believe me after 20
odd years in the business I've got
experience in this department and the
golden rule for successes don't get
intimidated get organized here are three
of my ultimate dishes for a great
evening party
[Music]
if there's one thing all the Ramsay
children love it's a good family party
and my eldest Megan is going to help me
with the party piece
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away that's away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's cool but the slower you cook it the
more juice it is and it's great for big
parties because you just come along and
get your fork and shred it a delicious
Smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay I'm Gonna
Leave the roots on okay because I want
this to sit underneath the port
it gives a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you to crush the garlic
we're gonna make a really nice little
paste okay
come on Mickey
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more Crush
come on me okay
oh sorry
cut there now this
is a beauty paprika smoke paprika I love
it so three nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons of brown
sugar
salt place and pepper good girl
[Laughter]
so I'm going to form a nice paste now
olive oil in
is that some thyme in there so we got a
sort of fragrant rub time stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now this is where you've got to be
really quick
okay
I've rubbed that massage it in almost
that's exactly that
smells amazing we'll see just drizzle a
little touch of olive oil on top of that
for me
I keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right it's quite easy as
well to make it's very easy five and a
half to six hours in the oven at 140.
while I pork butt slowly roast Meg and I
are gonna prep some shop bought
mayonnaise I don't like just plain
mayonnaise there's so many things you
can twist yeah there's so many things so
many exciting things you can do with it
right
salt pepper and
no touch of Honey sweetness yeah
sweetness but there's some heat coming
okay and I've got a little bit of you
know this Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste
I love that once you've made this
dressing you know it can sit in the
fridge great for open sandwiches yeah
can you use it for any sandwiches really
any sandwiches but goes brilliantly well
with pork now just have a little taste
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finally diced sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chop spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer
potatoes are equally delicious served
hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off I'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in teaspoon of sugar please die
a little small
cider vinegar there you go
finely chopped it up
in with the broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please
stop and then mix that up with me okay
a little taste
so good and it's kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
Chipotle now let me the pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
here
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious
before we go to the table just a little
bit honestly
don't tell mum thank you
good idea I'm gonna do it
now
so yeah you promised me you don't give
the recipe to your boyfriend that's good
[Music]
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipotle
mayonnaise
I'm quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw deliciously yummy dishes
that will have your family friends and
work buddies coming back for more right
[Music]
I love the chocolates
wow the sauce is a bit spicy dad nearly
blew my head off
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]